when i talk to people from new york and
jeddah died this one's going to you when
i talk to people from new york they tell
me they say the phone they say pat all
those people that left they are coming
back
they're all coming back no one's going
to stay in florida you have friends
there are people that left new york
coming back to new york not really no
especially if you owned a business and
that business went through a lockdown
and you had to shut it down and you had
to figure out other options and you
picked up your family and you picked up
your business and you went to a state
and now you're sitting in a place like
florida and you're realizing wait a
minute i can make a heck of a lot money
more money here because there's not as
much regulation the tax structure is
different and you've just experienced a
better life there's a lot of those
people there's also a lot of people i
think new york is going to have a really
challenging time because of the
structure that existed for a long time
around the office environment you have
all of these gigantic buildings they're
a fortune the rents are extraordinary in
new york city and now you have all this
remote work a lot of those companies are
not going back to in-office work i know
there's a call for a lot of them there's
a lot of them that are just not going to
go back into that structure there's a
lot of people who work in the tech field
companies like google they're not going
back into that structure you have all of
these
really big really expensive empty
buildings in new york city i don't know
what happens to those spaces i really
don't know
but a lot of the people that i talked to
that left are not going back some people
you know keep a little bit of a
footprint there they have family there
they have friends there but there's
really a growing distaste for
a lot of what new york city represents
now and until they get their crime
that's another thing you have some
people that it wasn't about a business
decision it was about a family decision
the crime was through the roof
they're in a place now where they feel
safe where they feel like their kid can
run around and play where they don't
feel like there's a hefty hand of
government where the police force feels
supported and they're saying even if i
do love new york city and what it
represents in my mind that's not what it
looks like today so new york city would
have to take a big step toward reversing
a lot of this damage um and i don't know
remember the prices have to be worth it
right it has to be worth it you have to
say well i'm going to be in the cultural
mecca of the world i'm going to be in
new york city that's not a good sell if
you can't walk through times square
without taking your life in your hands
it's very dangerous right now still so i
think a lot of these issues it's not if
it were just one issue it's not it's
like lockdowns it's mandates it's uh is
there going to be a second wave of this
and i'm going to go through this again
it's how dare you do that to my business
it's this heavy hand of government it's
crime it's it's multi-faceted the
reasons why people left cities like new
york california chicago so it's going to
take a lot to get those people to go
back and some of them just won't i won't
i i'll never go back remind you that
you'll never go back i will never go
back to living in new york and that's
home to you that's home i love my city i
love it i grew up there i like became
who i am there and i have a special bond
with it i don't know if i'll be in
florida forever but new york city it's
not
it's not what it once was you would have
to show me that new york city can be
amazing again and i'm not convinced that
new yorkers are going to vote for that
kind of leadership interesting and so
you know being from yonkers new york
shout out to my mom and my aunt that are
watching but uh yeah cause i could you
see it because it's a liberal state
right you think people would bounce and
then they'd be like you know what it's
over we're gonna come back but like you
said the crime is is nuts even my aunt
they don't walk outside at night there's
no chilling in in new york anymore it's
dangerous as [ __ ] and and the fact that
um
what was i saying uh
uh i lost my train of thought the fact
that the the fact that if you're a new
yorker and you're you love new york and
you bounce and now you're getting used
to this and now you want to come back
it's like come on you know what i mean
also you have to keep in mind you bring
up a good point about new york as a
state the state's not like that you go
upstate new york it's a different world
this is a new york city new york city is
sinking that state granted the governor
is a disaster she's an absolute monster
when it comes to any issue of freedom or
you know it's preposterous but
regardless that city is is sinking the
whole state so you have people living
great lives in upstate new york and
they're like ah they dread you know when
those policies trickle out from new york
and i'm pretty sure it doesn't help when
like the amazon was gonna open in new
york didn't they right what they're
trying to open in amazon and then aoc
and all them were like nah we don't want
you here don't yeah it's not business
friends
here yeah yeah take your business out
here okay yeah all right all right i'll
fight you by the way what you said about
um new york city is more liberal and
blue and the rest of the state that's
literally for every state you cannot
point to one major city in the country
not one yeah that voted red just so you
know yeah la new york chicago i'm just
i'm just letting you know every major
city votes blue and all rural votes read
and they're all sinking yeah so there
you go
exactly but anyway they are the major
cities in the country but here's my
point
i've
be you guys are from new york you're
from l.a well v iran
born and raised in miami i've i've only
lived here my entire life other than my
beautiful stint in addison texas that i
did for seven eight months you speak so
so lovingly about it adam you love texas
i burned out of my apartment never
looked back but i've been seeing new
yorkers
um i've said this before in the podcast
i've been seeing them play hopscotch
with south florida for 20 years now they
come down they have a great time on new
year's they live it up you know when i
was a club promoter back in the day
we're like the new yorkers are coming
we're charging triple the price you know
and then boom they'd pay it you'd make
some money peace out and i would always
wonder
when are these stupid suckers going to
realize what we have going on here year
round is better rather than just two
weeks for vacation yeah and it took a
freaking worldwide pandemic for them to
be like i'm done with this yeah and
obviously we're seeing what's happening
here now there's people in south florida
and some of our are holding mayor
francis swore as accountable who i voted
for i i really appreciate the guy
they're basically saying
you're bringing all these amazing people
here you're bringing crypto here look at
you know ken griffin citadel capital
they're all coming here what about us
yeah well i went to paying two thousand
bucks a month in rent now i gotta pay 2
900. i can't afford it so there's the
good and the bad of all these new
yorkers bringing 21 billion dollars
worth of wealth down to south florida or
florida in general yeah and by the way
what you just said is going to happen
you're going to see some of the people
who live in miami that can't handle that
kind of lifestyle they're going to live
30 minutes out
they're going to live 30 minutes out and
that happens in every city when they're
like when uh nikki fried was here and
she was talking about what about the
people that can't afford it in l.a it
happens as well people move to palmdale
california or lancaster
palm beach lancaster
everybody moved to palm beach lancaster
all of a sudden quartz hill was like
deep place and condo to live so that's
gonna happen as well the test i want i
want to challenge all of you guys this
week to do something
everybody knows somebody in new york
this week
i want you to ask your friends in new
york and see their reaction okay
ask them hey what do you think about
this 21 billion dollars of income lost
and you know the story that just came
out saying
300 000 people that left new york the
wealthiest and they're staying in
florida are you seeing people coming
back to new york do you have any stories
like that and just watch their reaction
because i said this i'm gonna do you one
better but don't finish yourself i said
this to somebody who's in the publishing
industry
and she was in the pr business her
reaction
was she was like offended oh really what
do you mean
everybody came back [ __ ] they just
left for that you you don't even know
what you're talking i'm like i'm just
asking a question how are things in new
york everybody comes back this is the
greatest city nobody will ever leave new
york okay that's great to you awesome
now you know it's great you're going to
new york i'm going to new york tomorrow
he's going to new york literally what i
was going to do he's going to new
i didn't know what i was going to film
exactly now you know that's that's great
perfect i will be there you'll help me
write some questions i will i'm going to
also what's really interesting is
because i have friends that are working
in the bar business right now and they
say
it's it's all tourists it's all the
tourists are have come back because they
can get in everywhere now the mandates
have dropped but the people who made it
like the new yorkers
they're not there like i even have a
friend who wanted to open up a hair
salon and she said my you know she was
working at another salon prior to cove
and she's like i want to open it up but
my my new yorkers aren't there anymore
it's like it's a very common type of
feel to it it's a very touristy here for
the moment i got you what you just said
so so it's it's funny you say that
because in la what's happening is a lot
of the guys that that are the the job
creators
those who are doers
they're friends who are doers left yeah
and they're stuck with some people that
are not doers so even though they may
love their state and they're staying
like scott rodriguez just commented
saying i'd love to leave a lot living on
a heartbeat but my family's there and my
wife my in-laws family is there so it's
hard for him to leave and shout out to
scott you know he uh uh gave a super
chat and wished everybody happy fourth
of july but a lot of people in l.a who
were like well i got to stay for my
family
it's very hard when you don't have
people to have dinner with or lunch with
or conversation with or just go shopping
or just hang out with like what happened
to these friends of mine they're leaving
that's an empty you may love your state
as much as you love you may love your
city as much as you love but generally
what you love about your city
is the culture and culture is the people
people when the people believe the city
is not the city it's just real estate
it's just land yes it's beautiful yes
it's great but it's what it's the people
in that city that make it great so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]